in diesem video zeige ich dir 340
kräuter obst und gemüsepflanzen die du
bei dir anbauen kannst auch wenn da in
die beete vielleicht im schatten liegen
also nicht den kopf in die erde stecken
denn du kannst immer noch eine ganze
menge weil die im garten anbauen auch
wenn es vielleicht nicht ganz so sonnig
ist wie du es gerne hätte aber klären
wir vielleicht erst mal wie statik es
auf deinen beten denn überhaupt sein
darf denn auf einem beet das niemals am
tag auch nur ein kleines bisschen sonne
abbekommt kannst du leider kein gemüse
anbauen es tut mir leid ich dazu
enttäuschen da könntest du es vielleicht
mit pilzen probieren und ganz vielleicht
mit feldsalat aber alles andere wird da
nicht wachsen wenn deine beete brauchen
mindestens und das ist wirklich das
minimum vier stunden sonne am tag damit
die pflanzen die ich dir hier vorstelle
da überhaupt wachsen können ganz ohne
sonne funktioniert das nicht mit dem
pflanzen unter synthese und dem rest des
tages über kann das beet aber gut und
gerne im schatten liegen und dann fangen
wir gleich mit einer ganzen gruppe von
gemüsen an die auch auf halbschattigen
beeten wachsen nämlich ganz viele
kohlgemüse kommen auch zu recht wenn sie
nicht so viel sonne bekommen
dazu gehört zum beispiel der weißkohl du
kannst also immer noch sauerkraut machen
auch wenn deine beete ein bisschen
schattiger sind blumenkohl und brokkoli
wachsen auch beide auf halbschattigen
bacon genauso wie der kohlrabi der
grünkohl und der rosenkohl diese ganzen
kohlgemüse kannst du auch auf
halbschattigen bieten anbauen das ist
gar kein problem wenn du cool gemüse
anbauen möchtest dann empfehle ich dir
immer ein schutznetz zu verwenden ich
weiß dass es doof ist und plastik im
garten zu verwenden und ich versuche das
auch wo es geht zu verhindern aber
kohlgemüse hat so viele diese schädlinge
die dir deine ganze ernte vermasseln
können wenn du nicht aufpasst und
innerhalb von drei tagen alles ab
könnten so fies und ich glaube ganz
viele von euch haben das schon erlebt
dass ich immer sage dann lieber gute
netze kaufen die jahre lang halten ich
habe meine netz jetzt glaube ich seit
sechs jahren und die sind immer noch
nicht kaputt die sehen aus wie neu oder
fast wie neu und ich kann die jedes jahr
wieder verwenden also wenn ihr
schutznetze kauft dann selbst auf eine
gute qualität ich kann euch gerne netze
in der video beschreibung verlinken die
ich verwende so dass ihr eure kohlgemüse
den ganzen schädlingen schützen können
damit ihr am ende auch noch was von
eurer ernte übrig habt und dann
ich auch immer darauf achten dass die
genug dünger haben denn die ganzen
kohlgemüse zumindest die die ich euch
jetzt hier aufgeführt habe sind stark
sera und die brauchen eine höhere
nährstoffbedarf ich gehe am ende des
videos noch mal darauf ein was man bei
der düngung in halbschattigen beten
etwas anders machen muss als auf
sonnigen beten also bleibt auf jeden
fall bis zum ende dran denn das ist
wichtig dass man das beachtet aber der
größte fehler den ich so sehe bei
hobbygärtnern ist dass sie ihren kohl
einfach zu wenig können wir sind schon
unglück die brauchen ein bisschen was du
sie groß und dick werden können die
zweite gemüse gruppe die auch im
schatten zurechtkommt sind die gänse fuß
gewechselt das heißt mangold spieler hat
und rote beete kannst du allesamt auch
in einem halbschattigen beat anbauen was
ist kein problem die brauchen nicht so
viel sonne und werfen da immer noch eine
tolle ernte ab gerade vom mangold bin
ich immer absolut begeistert wie der
abgeht und einfach ohne dass man
irgendwas tun muss einstecken nach dem
anderen produziert und das ist auch ein
super leckeres gemüse was man ja gar
nicht so oft im laden bekommt also
mangold würde ich auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren auch wenn du vielleicht
noch gar keine garten erfahrung hast und
rote beete und spieler hat wachsen auch
ziemlich ohne probleme also das sind
tolle anfänger freundliche gemüse die
auch auf halbschattigen bieten wachsen
dann kommen wir zur nächsten gemüse
gruppe das sind ziemlich schnell
wachsender kandidaten die auch im
halbschatten anbauen könnt ich habe ja
mal ein video über die raketen gewinne
so gemacht das kann ich euch gerne da
oben verlinken da sind die kandidaten
die ich jetzt hier erzähle ich auch alle
mit dabei
das ist einmal der salat also salat
wächst auch super gut im schatten da
braucht ihr euch überhaupt keine sorgen
machen auch radieschen die sind ja
sowieso total einfach an zu bauen also
salat und radieschen finde ich auch
immer toll für das beet von meinem sohn
zum beispiel der hat auch im beet in
unserem garten und da finde ich es immer
schön wenn man dann auch schnell eine
erste ernte hat sodass der auch merkt
dass da was rum kommt bei all der harten
arbeit dann all der salat ich weiß gar
nicht ob das kind weil fast alle leute
die bei uns in den garten kommen und
sich mal durch probieren durch die
ganzen gemüse die wir so anbauen kennen
kein apfel salat für uns ist das so
normal
das ist so ein schärferer salat der
er hält glaube ich senföle oder sowas so
dass er richtig schön würzig und scharf
schmeckt der wächst supergut auch jetzt
im winter wenn es draußen kalt ist kann
man den super toll noch ernten also
eigentlich ein super pflegeleichtes
tolles gemüse so muss die echt mal
ausprobieren und das könnt ihr auch auf
euren halbschattigen beten anbau und
dann kukula rucola wächst auch wunderbar
schatten macht auch ein bisschen pepp im
salat oder wieso nur kopfsalat finde ich
irgendwie bisschen öde aber wenn man
dann noch asia salat und rucola hat dann
wird das gleich viel freundlicher auch
im winter wenn man sonst nicht so viel
auswahl aus dem garten hat habe ich
nachts und kandidaten auf meiner liste
der irgendwie im winter auch einiges
hermacht wenn man trotzdem immer noch
jeden tag mit frischen salat auf dem
tisch haben möchte das ist der feldsalat
ich liebe feldsalat ich hasse ist zwar
den zu putzen
ich weiß nicht ob ich höre ich das immer
erzählt habe aber ich habe eine ur ur
großmutter die ich leider nie
kennengelernt habe und vor deren mir
meine familie mal erzählt weil sie
meinen ich hätte irgendwie die garten
leidenschaft von ihr geerbt und die
hatte anscheinend einen ganz tollen
garten die hat auch immer ihren karren
ist sie zum markt gefahren und hatte ihr
gemüse verkauft und die hat immer im
garten gesessen und feldsalat geputzt
und dann hat sie gesagt ich sitze hier
und kurz mädchen und während ich mag der
gibt ein küsschen
ich bin das erste super süß und werde
sie so gern mal in echt kennengelernt
und ihren garten gesehen ich kenne nur
ganz alte bilder auf unserem garten und
hessen wirklich trauen uns schön und ich
hoffe dass sie von oben runter schaut
und uns dann gerne zuschaut
aber gleichzeitig denke ich auch dass
sie sich das küsschen echt verdient hat
weil nüsschen oder feldsalat zu putzen
ich hasse es und freue mich immer wenn
ich das an meinen freund abschieben zwei
gemüse die aus unserem garten auf jeden
fall niemals wegzudenken wären die du
auch in halbschattigen beten anbauen
kannst sind karotten und pastinaken
karotten das muss ich glaub ich nicht
viel zu sagen pastinaken sind sehr
ähnlich ein bisschen müde aber
gleichzeitig süßer ein bisschen melitta
also man hat die früher auch statt
kartoffeln genommen und das war auch
grundnahrungsmittel für viele leute
früher
sie sind natürlich dicker und ja wenn
ihr noch nie pastinaken angebaut hat
macht das mal wir machen das auch total
auf das werden wir zum beispiel nudeln
mit tomatensoße kochen dann fragen wir
so beschriebene pastinaken stücke an
ganz scharf mit ein bisschen sojasauce
abgelöscht und die sind so würzig es ist
wie so ein paar mehr zahnersatz im
winter ist so lecker als ich hier
unbedingt mal ausprobieren und
zwiebelgewächse wachsen auch gut in
halbschattigen bieten die zwiebeln also
ganz normale gemüse zwiebeln oder auch
frühlingszwiebeln könnt ihr in
halbschattigen beten anbauen dann
knoblauch knoblauch könnte er auch jetzt
wieder pflanzen ich verlinke euch mal
mein knoblauch franz video da oben es
gibt zwei punkte um knoblauch zu
pflanzen einmal im herbst und einmal im
frühling und jetzt fängt die knoblauch
glanzzeit wieder an so dass ihr wieder
losgehen könnte zeigt bei euch kein
schnee liegt bei uns heute total viel
schnee deswegen bin ich auch heute hier
drin und nicht draußen im garten um das
video für euch zu bringen weil es kaum
noch ein durchkommen gibt schon den
lauch erwähnt ich glaube mich also der
auch gehört auch dass zudem könnt ihr
auch auf halbseitigen beten anbauen und
glaubwürdig auch unbedingt unter dem
kultur schützen jetzt anbauen weil die
lauf liege schon ziemlich hartnäckig ist
bei zwiebeln schaffen will es noch
meistens die zwiebel fliege ohne netz
abzuhalten indem wir sie in mischkultur
mit karotten oder pastinaken anbauen was
sie eine tolle mischkultur da kann ich
euch auch ein video unten in der video
beschreibung und hier oben verlinken wo
es um mischkulturen geht die pflanzen
die man gemeinsam auf ein bild zu lassen
kann damit sie sich die schädlinge
gegenseitig vom hals halten oder auf
eine andere art und weise einer da
irgendwie gut tun und jetzt weiß ich
überhaupt nicht was ich sagen wollte
aber ich habe auf jeden fall noch drei
gemüse im sinn
die auch anbauen können deswegen
manchmal mit denen weiter und zwar ist
es einmal der rettich ist so
anspruchslos und wenn ihr rechtlich
möglich weiß dass das spalten sich
irgendwie so ein bisschen die geister
ich bin nicht so ein krasser rettig fan
aber ab und zu finde ich schon nett und
der ideen kann man so einfach anbauen
der wächst einfach so freut die samen in
die erde und du kannst ein paar monate
später den rettich ernten und dann habe
ich noch zwei kandidaten die ich mir bis
zuletzt ausgehoben habe weil ich die so
toll finde
und das sind zwei fruchtgemüse die
anderen gemüse die ich euch jetzt hier
vorgestellt habe waren ja nur blatt und
wurzelgemüse weil die mit schatten viel
besser zurecht kommen aber bosch bohnen
und erbsen kommen auch auf
halbschattigen beten zurecht und die
können die auch bei euch anbauen ich
denke dass erweitert die palette doch um
zwei ganz tolle gemüse ich finde erbsen
ich bin mir immer unsicher ob erbsen
oder knollensellerie mein lieblings
gemüse sind vom geschmack her auf jeden
fall erbsen vom charakter her techno
sellerie der so günstig und witzig und
langsam und gemächlich wie die einfach
die will hässlichen knoll nicht sind sie
total charmant aber erstens sind einfach
so unglaublich lecker wenn man die
frisch vom strauch flick wir haben immer
mehr kinder zu besuch aus der
nachbarschaft die gerne mal im garten
ein bisschen umschauen und ein paar
sachen aschen und immer wenn ich den
erbsen gäbe sind die hin und weg und
sagen dass sie fast genau so sicher sind
wie süßigkeiten und das ist doch ein
tolles kompliment was man einem gemüse
machen kann
machen wir weiter mit den kräutern aber
ich finde ich habe mir jetzt zu den mund
fusselig geredet dass ich für die
kräuter die ihr im halbschatten anbauen
könnt jetzt einfach mal eine liste
einblenden so dass ihr die euch
abschreiben oder abfotografieren könnt
und dann mache ich weiter und es
herrlich noch was über die ganzen welt
sind eine ganze menge kräuter die auch
im halbschatten anbauen könnt und ich
denke sonst würde das video einfach viel
zu lange werden ich mache das immer so
dass sich die kräuter an den rand der
gemüsebeete pflanze so dass die gemüse
auch von der mischkultur mit den
kräutern profitieren weil viele kräuter
sind ja tolle mischkultur partner für
gemüse
und natürlich kann man auch ein
explizites kräuterbeet anliegen das habe
ich auch aber ich will das auch super
schön wenn man einfach an den wegen
entlang im gemüsegarten die kräuter hat
und die ernte man ja auch regelmäßig
also wenn wir kochen dann gehe ich
eigentlich immer raus in den garten und
tun uns erst mal frische kräuter und das
ist dann auch sehr einfach die zu ernten
wenn die direkt am weg entlang wachsen
und die gemüse profitieren eben noch von
dem mischkultur effekt also jetzt bin
ich eine ganz schöne sache und dann
machen wir weiter mit dem obst und da
kommt erst mein gemüse mit tatsächlich
weil höher mit einem gemüse obwohl wir
jetzt bei dem punkt angekommen sind
nämlich der rhabarber der ist ja
eigentlich ein gemüse aber wer
bezeichnet den schon ernsthaft als
gemüse außer er ist ein botaniker hat
also rhabarber wächst auch im
halbschatten und ist eine krasse pflanze
oder ich finde aber so wunderschön und
wenn ihr mal sehen wie wieder blüht also
lasst ihn ruhig mal blühen das ist
unglaublich aber eignet sich auch
wunderbar als solitär stauder also wenn
ihr zum beispiel einen bauerngarten
anlegt wie ich das ja auch in meinem
boot camp erkläre mit den
unterschiedlichen layout von
unterschiedlichen anlagen und
gemüsegärten es ist unglaublich wie
schön es ist wenn man in die mitte ein
rhabarber pflanzt und den aufblühen
lässt im sommer das ist wunderschön und
beerensträucher wachsen natürlicherweise
im wald das heißt die sind auch an
schatten oder halbschatten gewöhnt und
so könnt ihr also auch walderdbeeren
konnte heidelbeeren stachelbeeren
johannisbeeren brombeeren und himbeeren
auch in einem halbschattigen bereich
anbauen das ist überhaupt kein problem
im gegenteil eigentlich mögen die ist
sogar lieber als wenn sie in der prallen
sonne stehen und schattenmorellen könnt
ihr auch im halbschatten anbau und ich
glaube allerdings dass der name
schattenmorellen nicht daherkommt als
die auch im schatten wachsen falls es
jemand von euch weiß schreibt euch mal
in die kommentare ich habe da schon mal
was zu gelesen ich glaube es kommt
woanders ja aber auch weil es eine tolle
sache dann könnt ihr eure eigenen
sauerkirsche unten und nach
schwarzwälder kirschtorte mit kirschen
aus dem eigenen garten machen die könnt
ihr auch super eigens für ihren oder
einkochen es gibt
drei sachen die du beachten solltest
wenn du auf ihr halbschattigen oder
schattigen beten gärtner und zwar würde
ich den pflanzabstand also den abstand
zwischen den pflanzen immer ein bisschen
größe wählen als auf sonnigen beten
damit die pflanzen sich nicht auch noch
gegenseitig schatten machen und außerdem
brauchen pflanzen die im schatten
wachsen weniger wasser und weniger
nährstoffe als pflanzen auf sonnigen
bieten weil im schatten einfach alles
langsamer von statten geht das heißt du
musst auch länger darauf warten bis du
dann deine ernte bekommst und deswegen
brauchen die pflanzen nicht so viel
wasser nicht so viele dinge auf einmal
das ist übrigens unser wohnen wir haben
noch kein zimmer tieren
außerdem bat die kommen alle nach
hoffentlich stehen noch jede menge
umzugskisten herum und vor allem bin ich
erschüttert wie viele cds
mein freund hat guckt euch das mal an
unterschrieben jetzt noch weiter
unglaublich oder
er hat vor einem halben jahr nie vor
einem jahr wer zu sein vor einem jahr
angefangen cds zu sammeln
und jetzt ist unsere ganze wohnung 60
ich denke mal wenn du dieses video
schaut es dann grübelt du gerade an
deinem anbau planen jetzt wird der
fruchtfolge und der mischkultur und so
weiter funktioniert also auf jeden fall
mal da drüben vorbei da habe ich nämlich
ein video für dich verlinkt indem ich
dir genau zeige schritt für schritt wie
du deine anbauplanung erstellt und am
ende ist dieser anbau plan fertig
ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste woche
wieder gesangstag macht's gut